- On ne la voit plus que du haut
des airs, ou presque.
Marioupol, une ville martyrisée
dont l'horizon n'est plus
qu'un terrifiant fantôme.
Ceux qui restent piégés par
les bombes et l'encerclement
des troupes russes se terrent
dans les sous-sols encore
habitables, et meurt lentement
de faim.
Fuir cet enfer par ses propres
moyens, c'est ce que vient
de faire Irina. Contre toute
attente, elle a pu démarrer
le moteur de la carcasse de
sa voiture. Des motocyclistes
lui ont offert ce casque pour
la protéger d'un froid qu'elle a
dû endurer sur des centaines
de kilomètres.
Les premières bombes,
sa maison détruite, l'absence
d'électricité, d'eau,
de nourriture, la vie dans
les sous-sols sans aucune
nouvelle de ses proches, elle
croit encore les avoir rêvés.
Ce qu'elle sait c'est qu'il lui
fallait à tout prix sauver
sa vie et celle de sa fille.
Juste avant de partir, elle a
retrouvé sa mère dont elle était
sans nouvelles dans un quartier
voisin. Mais son père, lui, est
resté derrière. Sa tante aussi.
Du côté ukrainien, personne
ne viendra les chercher.
Les gens là-bas le savent.
Cet hypermarché de Zaporijia
s'est transformé en premier
accueil pour ceux qui risquent
tout pour sortir de Marioupol.
Katya dégage calme tout aussi
improbable que son sourire
apaisant. C'est la première fois
qu'elle peut changer la couche
de son nourrisson de 13 jours
sans s'inquiéter pour sa vie.
Vladimir est né alors que
le plafond du séjour
s'effondrait sous les obus.
La majorité arrive ici sous
le choc, épuisé et visiblement
affamé.
Dans les hôpitaux de Zaporijia,
les blessures physiques
des rescapés de Marioupol
dissimulent leur âme tout aussi
meurtrie. Natalia a mis plus
de 10 jours à pouvoir sortir
son mari d'un hôpital maintenant
occupé par les Russes.
"Il est fort, dit-elle, mais
il ne peut rien raconter
sans fondre en larmes."
Cette chance dont parle
Natalia, celle d'être sortis
vivants, elle n'offre aucun
soulagement, ici. Beaucoup sont
partis emportant avec eux
la culpabilité, celle d'avoir
laissé les leurs derrière. Quand
Ilona a été blessé, son père,
lui, est mort sur-le-champ.
Elle a dû se résoudre à laisser
une partie de sa famille
à Marioupol.
Ils y ont échappé, mais la mort
continue de hanter les dortoirs
des hôpitaux de Zaporijia.
Galina a été blessée dans
un bombardement. Elle était
terrorisée à l'idée de partir,
mais à Marioupol, elle n'aurait
pas survécu.
"On ne retrouvera jamais ceux
que l'on cherche, dit Galina,
ils ont vécu avec fierté toute
leur vie pour finir enterrer
dans des fosses communes, comme
des chiens." À Marioupol, tout
est mort, y compris l'humanité
et la dignité.